From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio International. Public Radio. Public Radio International.
来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。公共广播。国际公共广播电台。
So when I heard that a woman named Samantha Martin had trained raccoons to play basketball, and hires them out for parties and corporate events, I pictured raccoons. You know, in three-on-three or four-on-four games, in little Chicago Bulls uniforms. You know, Raccoon Scottie Pippen passes to Raccoon Dennis Rodman. Raccoon Michael Jordan, you know, takes it in for a layup or dunks it. The team is a little raccoon Orlando Magic or Los Angeles Lakers. I could see it all. But that is not what it was like. No, no, no. That was naive.
所以当我听说一个叫萨曼莎·马丁的女人训练浣熊打篮球，并把它们租出去用于派对和企业活动时，我脑海中浮现出的画面是这样的：浣熊。你知道的，进行三对三或四对四的比赛，穿着芝加哥公牛队的小球衣。浣熊斯科蒂·皮蓬传球给浣熊丹尼斯·罗德曼。浣熊迈克尔·乔丹带球上篮或者扣篮。这个队就像小浣熊奥兰多魔术队或洛杉矶湖人队。我完全能想象那个场景。但这根本不是那回事。不，不，不。那太天真了。
Ricky. Come here, Ricky. Ricky, Ricky. Snacks, hmm? There you go. Shoo. Shoo. Ricky, shoo. Come on, Ricky. Ricky, come here.
瑞奇。过来，瑞奇。瑞奇，瑞奇。零食，嗯？给你。去吧。去吧。瑞奇，去吧。来吧，瑞奇。瑞奇，过来。
Samantha Martin chases after one of her two basketball-playing raccoons, holding a bag of blue and pink cotton candy. She alternates, actually, between taking a fingerful of cotton candy for herself and giving one to the raccoon.
萨曼莎·马丁追赶着她两只打篮球的浣熊中的一只，手里拿着一袋蓝色和粉色的棉花糖。事实上，她交替着动作，一边自己捏一小撮棉花糖吃，一边喂给浣熊。
Yummy. Sugar. Sugar, Ricky. Come here. You don't want the snacks? Ricky, Ricky, Ricky.
好吃。糖。糖，瑞奇。过来。你不想吃零食吗？瑞奇，瑞奇，瑞奇。
Samantha is actually a skilled and successful trainer, but the animals are not cooperating this day, probably because Samantha went away for the holidays and they're still feeling neglected. Samantha puts a grapefruit-sized ball in the raccoon's hand and then pushes the raccoon's hand toward a Fisher-Price basketball net that rises perhaps a foot and a half off the floor.
萨曼莎其实是一位技术娴熟且成功的训练师，但这些动物今天并不配合，可能是因为萨曼莎去度假了，它们觉得被冷落了。萨曼莎把一个葡萄柚大小的球放在浣熊手中，然后把浣熊的手推向一个离地约一英尺半的费雪牌篮球架。
Oh, she missed. Shoot again. Shoot. Good girl.
哦，她没投中。再投一次。投。好孩子。
The fact is, there are things that raccoons like to do, are born to do. And playing basketball is not one of them.
事实是，有些事情是浣熊喜欢做的，是天生会做的。而打篮球并不是其中之一。
Oh, I know. It's frustrating. You have to have a lot of patience. Especially when I was first training them to play basketball, do you know how long it took me? It took me a month to get them to play basketball. Every day I had to come down here and play with ball, net, ball, net, treat. And you just see, going through their mind-- OK, if they touched the ball and then they touched the net, they'd get a treat. They'd be like ball, net, treat, treat. And then, I started getting them to hold the ball, and then I got them to push the ball into the net.
哦，我知道。这很令人沮丧。你必须要有很大的耐心。尤其是当我刚开始训练它们打篮球时，你知道我花了多长时间吗？我花了一个月才让它们打篮球。每天我都得下楼来，球、篮筐、球、篮筐、零食。你看着它们的思维过程——好吧，如果它们碰到球，然后碰到篮筐，它们就能得到零食。它们就会像这样：球、篮筐、零食、零食。然后，我开始让它们拿着球，接着我让它们把球推向篮筐。
And finally that day came where they picked up the ball off the ground and popped it in the net. And I was so thrilled. I was like, oh, they got it. He got excited. He was like, [PANTING SOUNDS] and he was picking up the ball and putting it in the net, picking up the ball and putting it in the net, over and over again. He got so excited.
终于，那一天来了，它们从地上捡起球，投进篮筐里。我太激动了。我说，哦，它们学会了。它很兴奋。它像这样（气喘声），它捡起球放进篮筐，又捡起球放进篮筐，一遍又一遍。它太兴奋了。
Taming animals means basically teaching them to conform to the human world, teaching them human expectations. And with many of the animals that Samantha raises, it's possible to make them more human while they're little. But then once they reach a certain age, their real animal nature kicks in. A baby cougar she was raising started stalking her friends, biting at their throats. The raccoons also go for the throat.
驯服动物基本上意味着教它们去适应人类世界，教它们符合人类的期望。对于萨曼莎饲养的许多动物来说，在它们幼小时把它们变得更人性化是可能的。但一旦它们到了某个年龄，它们真正的动物本性就会显露出来。她饲养的一只美洲狮幼崽开始跟踪她的朋友，咬他们的喉咙。浣熊也会攻击喉咙。
You know, if he's out of his cage, he'll run up. He'll look at you, and he'll recognize me as, like, Mom from years ago. He'll be like, Mom, and he'll race up to me, jump up, climb up to my shoulder, and then realize, wait, I'm wild, I don't like you anymore. And he'll bite my neck.
你知道，如果它跑出笼子，它会跑过来。它会看着你，它会认出我是多年前的“妈妈”。它会像这样：妈妈，然后它会冲过来，跳起来，爬上我的肩膀，然后意识到，等等，我是野生的，我不喜欢你了。然后它会咬我的脖子。
You see it inside. Their eyes go from crazy to tame, crazy to tame, crazy, crazy, tame, tame. It's almost like they're saying, no, Mom, love you-- must bite, must bite, must-- no, no, nice, nice, Mom, nice, oh, yes, we love Mom-- bite, must bite, must bite-- no, no. They just fight it. You just see this battle going on in their heads. They're like, [SOUNDS OF STRUGGLING].
你可以在它们眼里看到这种变化。它们的眼神从疯狂到温顺，疯狂到温顺，疯狂，疯狂，温顺，温顺。那感觉就像它们在说，不，妈妈，爱你——必须咬，必须咬，必须——不，不，乖，乖，妈妈，乖，哦，是的，我们爱妈妈——咬，必须咬，必须咬——不，不。它们只是在抗争。你就能看到它们脑子里正在进行这场战斗。它们就像这样（挣扎的声音）。
What do we want from animals? To run her business, Samantha has had to figure this out, and at parties, at corporate events, in commercials and films, Samantha has her raccoons pick pockets and play basketball. She has rats that bowl, rats that answer toy telephones?
我们从动物身上想要得到什么？为了经营她的生意，萨曼莎不得不弄清楚这一点。在派对、企业活动、广告和电影中，萨曼莎让她的浣熊表演扒窃和打篮球。她还有会打保龄球的老鼠，会接听玩具电话的老鼠？
Do people want to see animals do animal things?
人们想看动物做动物的事吗？
No, they don't. They want to see animals acting like people.
不，他们不想。他们想看动物表现得像人一样。
Most of us, the only animals we ever see are animals who act like humans-- cats and dogs. We watch movies and TV shows and commercials that are filled with animals that fetch beers from the refrigerator and solve crimes. And we forget the sheer animalness of animals. We don't see it. Maybe we don't want to see it. Well, this brings us to the topic of today's program. From WBEZ, of course, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, The Animalness of Animals. Our show today in three acts.
我们大多数人唯一见过的动物是像人一样行事的动物——猫和狗。我们观看那些充满了从冰箱里拿啤酒和破案的动物的电影、电视节目和广告。我们忘记了动物纯粹的动物性。我们看不见它。也许我们不想看见它。好了，这把我们引向今天节目的主题。当然，来自WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是《动物的动物性》。我们今天的节目分为三幕。
Act One, Staging the Food Chain in a New York Apartment.
第一幕，在纽约公寓里上演食物链。
Act Two, Animal Court. That's an original radio play by David Sedaris.
第二幕，动物法庭。那是大卫·塞达里斯创作的一部原创广播剧。
Act Three, The Moment Humans Stopped Being Animals. That's a story by Scott Carrier. Stay with us.
第三幕，人类不再是动物的那一刻。那是斯科特·卡里尔写的故事。请继续收听。
Act One. You know, usually when we see pictures of animals, they're fluffy and cute or they are noble and dignified. Well, compare that to this set of photos by Catherine Chalmers. In this first picture, we have a caterpillar eating a tomato, a brightly-colored close up of that. In the second picture, a praying mantis eats the caterpillar. And in the third picture, a tarantula eats the praying mantis. Catherine Chalmers takes these pictures in her own apartment in New York City, where she also raises the animals that she feeds to each other. Paul Tough stopped by for a visit.
第一幕。你知道，通常当我们看到动物的照片时，它们是毛茸茸且可爱的，或者它们是高贵且庄严的。好吧，对比一下凯瑟琳·查尔莫斯的这组照片。在第一张照片里，我们看到一只毛毛虫在吃西红柿，那是明亮色彩的特写。在第二张照片里，一只螳螂在吃毛毛虫。在第三张照片里，一只捕鸟蛛在吃螳螂。凯瑟琳·查尔莫斯在纽约市的公寓里拍摄这些照片，她也在那里饲养那些被她互相喂食的动物。保罗·托夫过去拜访了一下。
Growing up, Catherine Chalmers wasn't really an animal person. She always had a pet or two, nothing unusual. Then a few years ago, she was working on these sculptures where she would take dead insects and glue them onto plants and flowers. She needed a lot of dead flies, more than she could buy anywhere, and so she decided to start raising live flies in a glass cage in the corner of her apartment. She would just let them breed and wait for them to die. But then one day, she picked up a camera and looked at the flies through a close-up lens.
在成长过程中，凯瑟琳·查尔莫斯并不是一个喜欢动物的人。她总是养一两只宠物，没什么特别的。几年前，她正在创作一些雕塑，把死昆虫粘在植物和花朵上。她需要很多死苍蝇，多到她在任何地方都买不到，于是她决定开始在公寓角落的玻璃笼里饲养活苍蝇。她只是让它们繁殖，然后等待它们死去。但有一天，她拿起相机，通过特写镜头观察那些苍蝇。
And the world changed. Because instead of just seeing patterns of swarming flies, I saw leg hairs and genitals and mouths and I saw them. And I saw their lives, how they would greet each other, and what they would do. And I could see them being born. I could see them having sex. I could see them eating. I could see them flying. I could see them hanging out. And it was great. It was fascinating. So I'd sit there for hours until they went to the bathroom on the glass enough that I couldn't see anymore. And that's when I kind of got hooked into animals past a certain point of return.
世界改变了。因为与其只看到苍蝇群的图案，我看到了腿毛、生殖器和嘴巴，我看到了它们。我看到了它们的生命，它们如何互相问候，以及它们会做什么。我能看到它们出生。我能看到它们交配。我能看到它们吃东西。我能看到它们飞翔。我能看到它们闲逛。那太棒了。这太迷人了。所以我会在那里坐上几个小时，直到它们在玻璃上排泄到我看不见为止。就在那时，我开始对动物着迷，达到了某种无法回头的地步。
She realized that there were two basic moments of life that she couldn't see in the flies' cage. She couldn't see them eating and she couldn't see them die. So she came up with this project that she called The Food Chain. She decided to raise a few different animals-- caterpillars, praying mantises, frogs, spiders-- and take pictures of each animal eating the one that came beneath it in the natural food chain.
她意识到在苍蝇笼里有两个基本的生命时刻她看不到。她看不到它们吃东西，也看不到它们死亡。于是她提出了一个项目，称之为“食物链”。她决定饲养几种不同的动物——毛毛虫、螳螂、青蛙、蜘蛛——并拍下每种动物吃掉自然食物链中位于其下方的那一种的照片。
When I first thought of this project, when it first dawned on me, what I was kind of fishing around for, it kind of made my stomach hurt. The idea of raising animals to be eaten, to photograph them specifically to be eaten, was repugnant and made me kind of sick. But the more I thought of it, the more interesting I thought it was.
当我第一次想到这个项目时，当它第一次在我脑海中浮现，我想我在寻找什么时，我的胃部一阵不适。饲养动物来供人食用，专门为了拍摄它们被食用而饲养它们，这种想法令人反感，让我感到有点恶心。但我想得越多，就觉得它越有趣。
And so Catherine began to fill her loft with animals. There isn't much furniture, but every surface has got terrariums and cages on it. Frogs and mealworms and a snake on one table. Goldfish in the kitchen to feed the frogs. Crickets which chirp constantly. A tarantula and two cages full of mice. On a spare corner of the table where the frogs and the snake live, she's got a lightbox set up, and we sit down there to take a look at some of her pictures.
于是凯瑟琳开始用动物填满她的阁楼。那里家具不多，但每个表面上都有玻璃容器和笼子。一张桌子上放着青蛙、黄粉虫和一条蛇。厨房里有金鱼用来喂青蛙。蟋蟀不停地鸣叫。还有一只捕鸟蛛和两个装满老鼠的笼子。在青蛙和蛇居住的桌子边角上，她架设了一个灯箱，我们在那里坐下来看看她的一些照片。
So this is basically The Food Chain.
这就是“食物链”的基本内容。
The photos don't look like normal nature photography. They look more like fashion shots. The animals are brightly lit and sharply focused, pictured against a clear white background.
这些照片看起来不像普通的自然摄影。它们看起来更像时尚大片。动物们在明亮的灯光下，焦点清晰，背景是干净的白色。
It starts with caterpillars that eat tomatoes. The praying mantises eat the caterpillars. And my original idea was for the tarantula to eat the praying mantises. But spiders are really undependable predators.
它从吃西红柿的毛毛虫开始。螳螂吃掉毛毛虫。我最初的想法是让捕鸟蛛吃掉螳螂。但蜘蛛是极其不可靠的捕食者。
If there were two emotions competing in Catherine Chalmers, her fascination with the food chain and her disgust with what she was doing, it becomes clear to me, as she shows me her work, that in the end, her fascination won out. She lays out a sequence of shots that begin with the praying mantis about to attack a caterpillar.
如果说凯瑟琳·查尔莫斯内心有两种情绪在博弈，即她对食物链的着迷和她对自己所做之事的厌恶，那么在这一刻，当我看着她的作品时，我很清楚，最终是她的着迷赢了。她展示了一组镜头，开头是螳螂准备攻击毛毛虫。
That's the part that's really great, is she springs on it, and she wraps her arms around it. And she just starts biting into it. And the thing's live and it's still kicking. And with the caterpillars, since all they do is eat, basically their body is just one long digestive system. And so whatever they are eating, as soon as she bites into it, it just spills out. So if they're eating leaves when she bites into it-- and this totally surprised me when it first happened. It comes out green, or it comes out bright red, the color of the tomatoes, or it comes out bright yellow, if you're feeding them yellow tomatoes. So I did different sequences of caterpillar with different color guts coming out.
那部分真的很棒，它猛扑上去，用手臂抱住它。它就开始啃食它。那个东西还活着，还在踢蹬。至于毛毛虫，因为它们只会吃，基本上它们的身体就是一条很长的消化系统。所以无论它们在吃什么，一旦它咬下去，里面的东西就会溢出来。所以如果它们在吃叶子，当它咬下去时——这在刚发生时让我非常吃惊。它出来的是绿色的，或者是鲜红色的（西红柿的颜色），或者是亮黄色的（如果你喂它们黄西红柿）。所以我用不同颜色的内脏溢出的毛毛虫做了不同的拍摄序列。
And it was just beautiful. I mean, I didn't know that an animal eating something live could be so attractive. It was like spilling a tube of paint out on a white piece of canvas. It just blobs out. It's gruesome, if you think about it in terms of your brother or your sister, but in terms of the fact that it is an insect and we seem less attached to the insect world than, certainly, the human world, it was very beautiful.
那真是太美了。我的意思是，我不知道动物吃活物可以这么有吸引力。它就像一管颜料挤在白色的画布上。它只是溢出来。如果你用兄弟姐妹的角度去想，那是令人毛骨悚然的，但鉴于它是一只昆虫，而且我们似乎不像对人类世界那样对昆虫世界有感情，那是非常美的。
You'd think it would be easy to take pictures of predators eating their prey. That's what they do, after all. But it turns out to be more complicated than just putting a couple of animals together and snapping away. There are considerations of timing and staging. When she tried to have frogs eat the praying mantises, the problem was the frogs were simply too fast. Photo One would show a hungry frog and a praying mantis, and Photo Two would just show a well-fed frog.
你可能觉得拍摄捕食者吃掉猎物会很容易。毕竟，这就是它们做的事情。但事实证明，这比把几只动物放在一起按下快门要复杂得多。需要考虑时机和布置。当她尝试让青蛙吃掉螳螂时，问题在于青蛙实在太快了。第一张照片显示的是一只饥饿的青蛙和一只螳螂，第二张照片就只显示了一只吃饱的青蛙。
Then there was the tarantula problem. Tarantulas can go for months without eating and days without moving. She put the spider and the praying mantis up on her set, and the tarantula would just stare at the praying mantis, completely still, one leg in the air, for hours. Finally in one session at three in the morning, after staring through her camera all night, Catherine got what she wanted. She slides the photos onto the lightbox.
还有捕鸟蛛的问题。捕鸟蛛可以好几个月不吃东西，好几天不移动。她把蜘蛛和螳螂放在拍摄点上，那只捕鸟蛛就会盯着螳螂，一动不动，一条腿悬在半空中，持续数小时。终于在凌晨三点的一次拍摄中，在整晚盯着相机镜头之后，凯瑟琳得到了她想要的。她把照片放进灯箱。
You see the shot where the two of them are looking at each other. And then basically the spider pounced on it and flipped it over. And the praying mantis is upside-down, still looking straight at you and perfectly alive, looking at you, as the spider is munching on the middle part of its body. And then you see his head, and his antennas are waving around, and then slowly the head gets drawn more and more into the jaws. And it's still alive. And then the spider basically mushes it up into a ball and extracts the juices out of it.
你可以看到它们互相对视的那张照片。然后基本上那只蜘蛛猛扑上去，把它翻了过来。螳螂倒立着，仍然直勾勾地看着你，完全活着，看着你，此时蜘蛛正在咀嚼它身体的中段。然后你可以看到它的头，它的触角在挥动，接着慢慢地它的头被一点点拖进颚里。它仍然活着。然后蜘蛛基本上把它揉成一个球，吸出它的汁液。
And it took maybe, I can't remember, maybe three or four hours for it to eat the whole thing. And for at least half of that time, the praying mantis was perfectly alive. And it was hard, because you'd spent so long raising this thing. It was really hard to see it being eaten alive like that and having it take so long.
大概花了，我不记得了，可能三四个小时才把整个东西吃完。在那期间至少有一半时间，螳螂是完全活着的。这很难，因为你花那么长时间养大这个东西。亲眼看到它被活活吃掉，而且过程持续那么久，真的很艰难。
At this point in The Food Chain, her pictures were becoming more and more vivid, but so was the suffering that she was watching through her lens.
在“食物链”项目的这个阶段，她的照片变得越来越生动，但她通过镜头目睹的痛苦也随之增加。
I got attached to the praying mantises. Yeah, seeing the praying mantises die was definitely much harder than seeing the caterpillars dying. Unlike most insects, they have a head that moves, like ours does, on a neck. And so they turn and they look at you. And they've got these big eyes sticking out. And they have some of the characteristics of the things which usually win human sympathy, which is big eyes and kind of an expression. And their mouth is red on the inside. So when they would eat something, it looked like they had red lipstick on. It was much easier to get attached to them.
我对螳螂产生了感情。是的，看到螳螂死去绝对比看到毛毛虫死去要艰难得多。不像大多数昆虫，它们的头能在脖子上像我们一样移动。所以它们会转过头来看你。它们还有巨大的、向外突出的眼睛。它们具有一些通常能赢得人类同情的特征，那就是大眼睛和某种表情。而且它们的嘴内部是红色的。所以当它们吃东西时，看起来就像涂了红色唇膏一样。对它们产生感情要容易得多。
One of the things that the Food Chain photos have made Catherine think about is how we humans choose which animals we love and which ones we hate, the distinction we make, basically, between pets and pests. She says most of us are attracted to animals that are like us, that are mammals, that have round faces and big eyes like human infants. And she's not immune to that instinct. Her favorite animal is her dog, Leo. But she also finds herself drawn to the animals that we are supposed to fear, and the moments in their lives that we usually turn away from.
“食物链”照片让凯瑟琳思考的一件事是，我们人类如何选择我们所爱的动物和我们所厌恶的动物，也就是我们在宠物和害虫之间做出的区分。她说我们大多数人会被像我们一样的动物吸引，那些哺乳动物，那些像人类婴儿一样有圆脸和大眼睛的动物。她也无法抵御这种本能。她最喜欢的动物是她的狗，里奥。但她也发现自己被那些我们理应恐惧的动物所吸引，被它们生命中那些我们通常会避开的时刻所吸引。
At the lightbox, she puts down four new photos from a different project, a series of shots of two praying mantises having sex.
在灯箱旁，她放下了四张来自不同项目的新照片，这是一系列两只螳螂交配的照片。
So that's the female. That's the male. She's a lot bigger. Then they mated. They look like a nice happy couple. He has green eyes. She has brown.
那是雌性。那是雄性。她要大得多。然后它们交配了。它们看起来像一对幸福的伴侣。他有绿眼睛。她有棕色的。
So he's on top of her.
所以他在她上面。
He's on top of her. And it's just like a classic doggy-style sex position. And they stay that way for hours. Hours and hours and hours. I mean, I'll take a few pictures, come back in 20 minutes, take a few more pictures, come back in 20 minutes.
他在她上面。这就像经典的男上女下交配姿势。它们就这样保持了好几个小时。几个小时，几个小时又几个小时。我的意思是，我会拍几张照片，20分钟后再回来，再拍几张，20分钟后再回来。
Isn't that kind of rare for animals? I thought animals were sort of-- do it quick.
这对于动物来说不是很罕见吗？我以为动物通常是……速战速决。
So did I, especially insects. I don't know. I think it's somewhat rare. I was surprised. I mean I've waited four hours and finally just went to bed and woke up in the morning, and the male is nowhere to be found.
我也是这么想的，尤其是昆虫。我不知道。我觉得这有点罕见。我很惊讶。我的意思是，我等了四个小时，最后只好去睡觉，早上醒来时，雄性已经不知去向了。
But then one time, instead of him getting completely off of her, she caught him and wrapped her arms around him, like she was holding him around the neck, like walking arm in arm. And she just started eating him. I couldn't believe it. I've mated them two years in a row now and hadn't had them do that.
但有一次，他没有完全从她身上下来，她抓住了他，用手臂围住他，就像搂着他的脖子，像挽着胳膊走路一样。然后她就开始吃他。我简直不敢相信。我连续两年让它们交配，之前都没发生过这种情况。
The photos aren't exactly grisly. There's no blood, not really even any color, but they're still pretty disturbing.
这些照片并不完全是可怕的。没有血，甚至没有什么颜色，但它们仍然让人非常不安。
Here, you see he's still kind of halfway on, and she reached around and grabbed him by the neck and bit his face off. See, he has no head there.
这里，你可以看到他还处于半上去的状态，她转过身抓住他的脖子，把他的脸咬掉了。看，那里他没有头了。
What's that?
那是什么？
Oh, that's one of his arms. There was kind of a fight. It's like the tip somewhere. And she's eating straight down his abdomen. See, he's already past his waist. Whatever. She finished when she got there. She even ate some of the wings, munched on some of those.
哦，那是他的一只胳膊。之前好像发生了一场打斗。可能是尖端什么的。她正顺着他的腹部往下吃。看，他已经过了腰部。随便吧。她吃到了那里就结束了。她甚至吃掉了一些翅膀，啃掉了一些。
And when does he die?
他什么时候死的？
When does he die?
Do you think he's dead there?
你觉得他在那里已经死了吗？
Well, insects, it's like their bodies are more democratic. They don't have a central nervous system the same way we do. You bite their head off, and the whole theory is that their body keeps functioning. So she can bite his head off when they're in this position, having sex, and he continues to have sex with her and continues to give her sperm, or whatever they call it in bug stuff. And there were some scientists who measured the inside of her cavity. And when she bit his head off, she got more sperm. So his head actually acted as an inhibitor, and when that's gone, then she gets the rest. So in the cases where the female bit the head off, she actually got more sperm. I suppose theoretically, therefore, more of her eggs are fertilized.
嗯，昆虫，它们的身体更加民主。它们没有我们那样的中央神经系统。你咬掉它们的头，整个理论是它们的身体继续运作。所以当它们处于这种姿势、正在交配时，她可以咬掉他的头，他继续与她交配，继续给她精子，或者随便它们在昆虫界里叫什么。有些科学家测量了她体腔内部的情况。当她咬掉他的头时，她得到了更多的精子。所以他的头实际上起到了抑制作用，而当它消失后，她就得到了剩下的部分。所以，在雌性咬掉雄性头的情况下，她实际上得到了更多的精子。我想从理论上讲，因此，她更多的卵子受精了。
What do you mean, his head acts as an inhibitor?
你是什么意思，他的头起到抑制作用？
Well, he's very cautious around her. And his caution seems to originate in his head. So at this point, he's definitely still alive, when she's only eaten his face off.
嗯，他在她周围非常谨慎。而他的谨慎似乎起源于他的头。所以此时此刻，当她只咬掉他的脸时，他绝对还活着。
At the center of Catherine's studio, there are two glass cages where her mice live. There are about 20 mice in each cage, of all ages. Some have just been born, still nursing from their mothers, some pregnant, some have been around for a few generations. It's the nicest part of the studio. The mice are all very clean and healthy and cute, and the cage even smells good. These mice are the centerpiece of Catherine's current project. She photographs them being born, and then photographs them being eaten by various predators.
在凯瑟琳工作室的中心，有两个老鼠居住的玻璃笼子。每个笼子里大约有20只不同年龄的老鼠。有些刚出生，还在吮吸母乳，有些怀孕了，有些已经繁衍了好几代。这是工作室里最美好的一部分。老鼠们都很干净、健康、可爱，笼子甚至闻起来很香。这些老鼠是凯瑟琳当前项目的核心。她拍摄它们出生，然后拍摄它们被各种捕食者吃掉。
Today she's going to take pictures of a two-day-old mouse, which is called a pinkie because it's too young to have fur. It just has pink skin. Its eyes are still closed, and it can barely move. Her 10-inch, pencil-thin snake, Pumpkin, hasn't eaten in almost a week. Today, Pumpkin's going to eat a pinkie.
今天她要给一只两周大的老鼠拍照，它被称为“粉红仔”，因为它太小了，还没有长毛。它只有粉红色的皮肤。眼睛还是闭着的，几乎不能动。她那条10英寸长、铅笔细的蛇，南瓜，已经快一周没吃东西了。今天，南瓜要吃掉一只粉红仔。
She puts the pinkie and the snake up on what she calls her set. This is where she takes all her pictures. It's chest-high, about three feet by three feet, with a white Formica surface that curves up at the back to form a seamless background. There are only two strobe lights, plus a third light underneath the surface to make sure the animals stay warm.
她把粉红仔和蛇放在她所谓的拍摄点上。这是她拍摄所有照片的地方。它齐胸高，大约三英尺乘三英尺，有一个白色福米卡表面，向后弯曲形成一个无缝背景。只有两盏频闪灯，加上表面下方的一盏灯，以确保动物保持温暖。
Do you have to keep the snake away from the pinkie when you first put it down?
你第一次把它放下去的时候，必须让蛇远离粉红仔吗？
No. It takes a while to figure out that it's there.
不。它需要一会儿才能发现它在那里。
Now, the pinkie started moving. Do you think--
现在，粉红仔开始移动了。你觉得——
No. I don't think the pinkie understands there's a snake there.
不。我不认为粉红仔明白那里有一条蛇。
The snake's moving slowly, putting its head up right next to the pinkie and flicking out its tongue as if it wants to lick it.
蛇缓慢地移动着，把头抬起来靠在粉红仔旁边，吐出舌头，好像它想舔它。
She's checking it out, smelling it, sniffing it, making sure it's OK, I guess.
它在检查它，闻它，嗅它，确保它没问题，我想。
It's very friendly.
它看起来很友好。
I don't know if I'd call it friendly.
我不知道我会不会称之为友好。
I mean it just looks that way, the two of them together.
我的意思是，它们在一起看起来就是那样的。
The two of them hanging out together. Yeah. Their faces are about the same size. Well, no, the mouse's face is bigger. You see what I mean? There's no terror in the mouse.
它们两个待在一起。是的。它们的脸差不多大。嗯，不，老鼠的脸更大。你明白我的意思吗？老鼠身上没有恐惧。
But the mouse doesn't look that happy.
但老鼠看起来并不那么开心。
Well, hard to tell what makes something that small unhappy.
嗯，很难说是什么让那么小的东西不开心。
stood there for 15 minutes watching as the snake tried to decide what to do. The pinkie didn't move much, just sort of quivered, raising its head every once in a while. Then, finally, the snake made its move.
站在那里观察了15分钟，看那条蛇试图决定该做什么。粉红仔没怎么动，只是稍微颤抖了一下，偶尔抬起头。然后，最后，那条蛇采取了行动。
Hmm. Very strange.
嗯。非常奇怪。
What was strange was the way the snake attacked. Pumpkin is a constrictor, which means that usually when it goes for its prey, it quickly wraps its body around it and squeezes it to death.
奇怪的是那条蛇攻击的方式。南瓜是一条蟒蛇，这意味着通常当它去攻击猎物时，它会迅速把身体缠绕在猎物身上，将其挤死。
It hasn't happened like this before.
之前没发生过这样的事。
This time it bit the pinkie and held it in its fangs, alive, for a couple of minutes before it finally constricted it.
这次它咬住了粉红仔，并用毒牙含着它，让它活着，过了几分钟才最终将其勒死。
Does the pinkie always struggle like that?
粉红仔总是那样挣扎吗？
No, and it has never squealed before.
不，而且它以前从没尖叫过。
What's the difference, do you think?
你认为有什么不同之处？
The pinkie was bigger, older.
粉红仔更大，更老了。
Is it still alive now?
它现在还活着吗？
If you look at the tail, you can usually tell. When the tail starts to droop down. Although it's getting so much blood pushed through there that that could keep it up.
看尾巴通常就能判断。当尾巴开始垂下来的时候。不过，因为有大量的血液流经那里，所以它或许还能保持挺立。
I know you can be charged for being cruel to a dog. Can you be charged for being cruel to a mouse?
我知道虐待狗可以被起诉。那虐待老鼠可以被起诉吗？
No, I don't think so. Now, maybe if I took one of my mice, went out into the middle of Broadway, and started ripping it apart where everybody could see-- I don't know. And probably a legal person wouldn't know, because it never comes up.
不，我不这么认为。当然，如果我带着一只我的老鼠，走到百老汇大街中间，在众目睽睽之下把它撕碎——我不知道。法律界人士大概也不知道，因为这从未发生过。
Catherine says that we've developed a hierarchy of death. Some animals we're prohibited from killing. Some we're encouraged to kill. And most of them we just don't care about. I asked her whether doing the Food Chain project changed the way she saw animals. And she said that it hadn't changed the way she saw them, it made her see them for the first time. Before she started photographing animals, she was like most people. She never really thought about them at all.
凯瑟琳说我们已经建立了一种死亡等级制度。有些动物我们被禁止杀害。有些我们被鼓励去杀。而大部分动物我们根本不在乎。我问她，“食物链”项目是否改变了她看待动物的方式。她说并没有改变她看待它们的方式，而是让她第一次真正看见了它们。在她开始拍摄动物之前，她和大多数人一样，根本没怎么想过它们。
And do you ever feel like you're taking sides when you set up a photograph like this?
当你布置这样的摄影场景时，你是否会觉得自己选边站了？
Yeah, your sides change. Yeah. I mean, at one point, you feel really bad about the pinkie, and at one point, you're really happy your snake ate and therefore it's healthy and it's going to live. So in something like this, your sides always change. And when you put the pinkie up there, before you put the snake up there, you feel really bad. You think, oh, well, this little thing doesn't know it's about to be eaten. And with the Food Chain project, that was one of the points. You take the side of the underdog, and then the underdog becomes a predator, and then you have to change sides again, and then you change sides again. And it's arbitrary and relative anyways. So you just kind of get all confused, really.
是的，你的立场会变。我的意思是，某一刻，你会对那只粉嫩幼鼠感到非常愧疚，而另一刻，你又会为你的蛇吃了东西感到高兴，因为它很健康，可以活下去。所以像这种情况下，你的立场总是在变。当你把粉嫩幼鼠放进去，在放入蛇之前，你会感觉很糟糕。你会想，哦，这个小东西还不知道它马上就要被吃了。对于“食物链”项目来说，这就是要点之一。你站在弱者一边，然后弱者变成了捕食者，接着你又不得不改变立场，然后你再次改变立场。无论如何，这都是武断且相对的。所以实际上，你只会感到困惑。
It's getting to the point with the mouse project where those feelings are starting to have real repercussions. Right now, Pumpkin can't eat anything bigger than a pinkie, but she's growing. Eventually she'll be three feet or more. Before long, she'll be eating full-grown mice, the ones that Catherine feeds and holds and plays with every day.
对于老鼠项目，事情发展到了那种感觉开始产生实际影响的地步。目前，“南瓜”（Pumpkin）吃不下比粉嫩幼鼠更大的东西，但它在长大。最终它会达到三英尺或更长。不久之后，它就会吃成年老鼠了，就是凯瑟琳每天喂养、抱在怀里并与它们玩耍的那些。
It's one thing, I was telling you this before, to feed something to something where the pinkie has no senses yet. It can't see. It can smell, but it can't see. But it's another when you pick up a full-grown mouse who is aware of what's going on when it sees a snake. And I don't know what I'm going to do when she starts eating full-grown mice. Right now, it's still something within the realm of something I can do. I don't know. Is there a line at which it starts being hard to do? Yeah, probably.
就像我之前跟你说的，给某种生物喂食粉嫩幼鼠是一回事，因为它们还没有知觉。它看不见。它能闻到，但看不见。但当你拿起一只成年老鼠，它能意识到当看到蛇时发生了什么，这完全是另一回事。我不知道当它开始吃成年老鼠时我该怎么办。目前，这还在我能接受的范围内。我不知道。是否存在一条界限，越过它就变得难以接受？是的，可能存在。
Catherine talks about her apartment being like an oasis in the middle of Soho. She loves coming home from the cars and concrete of Manhattan into a place that's filled with life. But in another way, it's Manhattan, it's our world, that's the oasis in the middle of a planet that's full of nature. All around us, things are eating and having sex and dying and suffering, and we don't notice or even think about it.
凯瑟琳说她的公寓就像索霍区中间的一片绿洲。她喜欢从曼哈顿的汽车和水泥地回家，进入一个充满生命的地方。但从另一个角度看，曼哈顿——我们的世界——才是那片绿洲，而它位于充满大自然的星球中心。在我们周围，万物在捕食、繁衍、死亡和受苦，而我们却从未注意，甚至从未思考过。
Do you think the pinkie's still alive?
你觉得那只粉嫩幼鼠还活着吗？
No. It's getting kind of blue.
不。它开始有点发青了。
So did you feel weird at all when he was squealing at the end? Did that make you feel strange at all?
那你听到它最后尖叫的时候，有没有感到奇怪？那有没有让你觉得古怪？
Well, you never really like something to suffer. And it definitely was not very happy. But the pinkie was going to die anyways.
嗯，你永远不会喜欢看到东西受苦。它肯定很不开心。但那只粉嫩幼鼠无论如何都是要死的。
I guess there's a difference if it's being fed, if there's a purpose to it, if it's part of the chain.
我想，如果是为了喂养，如果这是一种目的，如果它是链条的一部分，那还是有区别的。
Well, it's no different to the snake. The snake doesn't really seem to care if the mouse squeals or not. Is it any different to the mouse? Yeah, maybe a little bit, but it's dying anyways. It dies a little faster, or it dies a little slower possibly. So I cared more. The snake didn't care. Who knows if the mouse did. So who matters? Whose opinion do I go by here? Why should I go mine?
嗯，这对蛇来说没什么不同。蛇似乎并不在乎老鼠是否尖叫。这对老鼠有什么不同吗？也许有一点，但它反正都要死。它可能死得快一点，或者死得慢一点。所以我更在乎。蛇不在乎。谁知道老鼠在乎不在乎呢？那谁的感受才重要？我该遵循谁的观点？为什么我要采纳自己的？
At the end of our photoshoot, Catherine carefully picks up the snake and carries it back to its cage. There's a bulge about a third of the way down the snake's body where the pinkie is being digested. Before I leave, Catherine pours us a glass of wine, and we sit on the floor for a little while playing with a couple of her full-grown mice, letting them run over our hands and up our arms. They're tiny and warm, and through their fur, we can feel their little hearts beating.
在我们的拍摄结束时，凯瑟琳小心翼翼地拿起蛇，把它带回笼子里。蛇身下方约三分之一处有一个凸起，那里是正在消化的粉嫩幼鼠。我离开前，凯瑟琳为我们倒了一杯酒，我们在地板上坐了一会儿，和她的几只成年老鼠一起玩耍，让它们在我们的手上和手臂上跑来跑去。它们小小的，暖烘烘的，透过它们的皮毛，我们能感觉到它们小心脏的跳动。
[MUSIC -- "INSECT COLLECTOR" BY SHONEN KNIFE]
[音乐 -- "INSECT COLLECTOR" BY SHONEN KNIFE]
Paul Tough. Catherine Chalmers' pictures are in a book called Food Chain: Encounters Between Mates, Predators, and Prey.
保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）。凯瑟琳·查尔默斯（Catherine Chalmers）的照片收录在名为《食物链：配偶、捕食者与猎物之间的邂逅》（Food Chain: Encounters Between Mates, Predators, and Prey）的书中。
Coming up, animal radio theater by David Sedaris, and animal research from Scott Carrier. That's all in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来是戴维·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）带来的动物广播剧，以及斯科特·卡里尔（Scott Carrier）的动物研究报告。节目继续后，公共广播国际公司（Public Radio International）将在不到一分钟的时间里为您播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a topic, and tackle that topic with documentaries, short fiction, radio monologues, found tape, anything we can think of. Today's topic, animals and the animalness of animals. We've arrived at Act Two of our program, which is basically more animals eating other animals.
这里是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。每周我们都会在节目中选择一个主题，并通过纪录片、短篇小说、广播独白、找到的录音等任何我们能想到的方式来探讨该主题。今天的主题是：动物以及动物的“动物性”。我们已经进入节目的第二幕，基本就是更多动物吃掉其他动物的内容。
But first a little story. A little girl is given a new sweater, an ugly new sweater which she hates. She takes the sweater, puts it on the floor, takes a nap, and when she wakes up, her sweater's been chewed to shreds. She, of course, could not be happier, but her mother's very upset, cries a little. The girl blames the dog, a little spaniel named Kathleen.
但首先是一个小故事。一个小女孩收到了一件新毛衣，一件她讨厌的丑毛衣。她把毛衣放在地板上，去睡了个午觉。等她醒来时，毛衣已经被咬成了碎片。她当然高兴坏了，但她母亲非常生气，哭了起来。小女孩把责任推给了那条名叫凯瑟琳（Kathleen）的小猎犬。
I demand a fair hearing. I won't take the blame.
我要求进行公正审判。我绝不背这个锅。
Kathleen the spaniel then stood to proclaim.
凯瑟琳（猎犬）站出来宣称。
I didn't do nothing. I'm just not the sort. I'll see you in hell first, or animal court.
我什么都没做。我不是那种狗。我宁愿在地狱或动物法庭上见到你。
David Sedaris has written a play for our program. This play is an original radio play entirely in rhymed couplets. In this play, the animals do lots of things that humans do. For example, they talk. And they hold court out in the forest. But in this play, also, every now and then-- unlike most fairy tales, unlike most movies about animals or stories about animals-- these animals reassert their animalness.
戴维·塞达里斯为我们的节目写了一部剧。这是一部完全由押韵对联构成的原创广播剧。在这部剧中，动物们做了很多人类会做的事情。比如，它们说话。它们在森林里开庭。但在剧中，每隔一段时间——与大多数童话故事、大多数关于动物的电影或故事不同——这些动物会重新彰显它们的“动物性”。
Our play begins as Kathleen the spaniel heads out into the forest and our narrator, the little girl who owns her, follows behind.
故事开始于猎犬凯瑟琳走进森林，而它的主人——那个小女孩——跟在后面。
I waited till late and crept out. It was dark. I was deep in the forest when I heard a bark. It was Kathleen, my spaniel, kneeling before an old dog, a judge. And this elder, he wore a dark floor-length robe. I think it was silk. He paused then and lapped from a bowl of skim milk.
我等到天晚才悄悄溜出来。天很黑。我在森林深处听到了一声吠叫。那是凯瑟琳，我的猎犬，跪在一只老狗——法官面前。这位长者穿着一件深色的拖地长袍。我想是丝绸做的。它停顿了一下，然后舔了一口碗里的脱脂牛奶。
This court is in session. Oh, Jesus, I oughtta lay off the scraps when they serve enchiladas.
法庭现在开庭。噢，老天，它们端上恩奇拉达卷（enchiladas）的时候，我真该少吃点剩菜。
He patted his chest with potato-sized paws, then pounded his gavel and laid down the law.
它用土豆大小的爪子拍了拍胸口，然后重重地敲下法槌，定下了规矩。
There'll be no witness-leading, no swearing or shedding, no tampering, catcalls, or evidence-shredding. I call on the state now to start prosecution. Defense will then counter to prove absolution.
不得引导证人，不得撒谎或推卸责任，不得篡改证据、起哄或毁坏证物。现在我要求控方开始陈述。辩方随后反驳以证明无罪。
The clearing was silent. A cat took the floor, a smooth-talking tongue with a high pompadour.
林间空地一片寂静。一只猫走上前来，它谈吐圆滑，留着高耸的发型。
Your Honor, destruction's no small misdemeanor. The accused here is vicious. We should quarantine her. Now I plan to prove beyond reasonable doubt that Kathleen the spaniel engaged in a bout of senseless destruction. She's got no remorse, a fact that I'm hoping to prove in due course. I call to the stand now one eyewitness worm. She was there on the scene. Her memory's firm.
法官大人，毁坏物品不是什么小罪。被告心狠手辣。我们应该把它隔离。现在我打算证明，毫无疑问，猎犬凯瑟琳进行了毫无意义的破坏。它毫无悔意，我希望在审理过程中证明这一点。现在我传唤证人——一条蠕虫。它当时就在现场。它的记忆力很好。
It seemed like a lifetime. The worm took forever to inch to the stand and begin her endeavor.
仿佛过了一辈子。那条蠕虫用了很久才挪到证人席，开始它的证词。
Yes, I'm a worm, true. I live in the soil. Only in rain do I earthwards unfoil. On this day in question, we had a fierce shower, so using my well-known abdominal power, I lifted myself from the earth's muddy ground. I crawled and I climbed and eventually found myself on a window ledge, me, just a worm, a fact I would like to now briefly confirm. My eyesight is faultless. I know what I've seen. The defendant herself, the spaniel Kathleen, engaged in destruction against this thing's sweater. She used it as a sort of an appetite-whetter. She gnawed at the fabric and tugged at the collar, and knowing no way I could stop her or stall her, I stood a mute witness. I watched in disgust. I think it's appalling. I find it unjust. That dog's no puppy. She should have known better than to lie on a mattress digesting a sweater. If you want my opinion, I think you oughtta put her away. She's a heinous marauder.
是的，我是条蠕虫，没错。我住在土壤里。只有下雨时我才爬出地面。在那个问题日期，我们下了一场大雨，所以利用我众所周知的腹部力量，我把自己从泥泞的地上提了起来。我爬啊爬，终于发现自己在窗台上，我，只是一条蠕虫，这一事实我现在想简要确认一下。我的视力没问题。我知道我看到了什么。被告本人，猎犬凯瑟琳，对这件东西的毛衣进行了毁坏。它把它当作一种开胃菜。它啃咬面料，拉扯领口，我知道我无法阻止它，所以我站在一旁，做了个沉默的证人。我看得恶心。我认为这令人发指。我发现这很不公平。那条狗不是幼犬。它应该知道，躺在垫子上消化一件毛衣是不对的。如果你想听我的意见，我觉得你应该把它关起来。它是个十恶不赦的掠夺者。
The worm had concluded. She'd finished her say and reached for a thimble of cold consomme.
蠕虫说完了。它讲完了它的证词，伸手去拿一个装满冷清汤的顶针。
Your witness.
证人交给你了。
The cat said. I watched as a wren hopped to the floor where the cat once had been.
猫说道。我看着一只鹪鹩跳到了地板上，那是猫刚才站的地方。
Your Honor, it's clear that this worm is deceptive. I'm wondering now if she might be receptive to proving her eyesight is all that she claims. I'd like her to read from this short list of names.
法官大人，很明显这条蠕虫在撒谎。我现在想看看它是否能证明它的视力像它声称的那样好。我想让它从这张短名单上读出名字。
The bird took a book written in Lebanese, and carried it out past the pond to the trees.
那只鸟拿出一本用黎巴嫩语写的书，带着它飞过池塘，到了树林里。
Can you read this name here? It's first on the list.
你能读出这里的这个名字吗？名单上的第一个。
That's too far away.
太远了。
The angry worm hissed.
愤怒的蠕虫嘶嘶叫道。
I can't read that far, not even in day. You might as well post it in Rome or Pompeii.
我看不见那么远，大白天也看不见。你不如把它贴到罗马或庞贝古城去。
So your sight--
所以你的视力——
Said the bird, keen on proving a point.
鸟说道，一心想证明观点。
Is something you boast upon when you anoint this court with your presence, the all-seeing worm. Your sight is on par with an old pachyderm. You're small and deceitful. You crawled to no ledge. You witnessed no crime like the one you allege.
就是你用以吹嘘的东西，当你用你的出现来“光临”这个法庭时，全知的蠕虫。你的视力简直和老象差不多。你又小又阴险。你根本没爬到什么窗台上。你没见过你所指控的那种罪行。
Stop talking to me in your harsh legalese. I know what I saw. I can't read Lebanese. Still, though, I saw it. I've seen lots of things. I've noticed you, pooch and take off on your wings. I know all about you. My word is my honor.
别用你那刺耳的法律术语跟我说话。我知道我看到了什么。我读不懂黎巴嫩语。不过，我还是看见了。我见过很多东西。我注意到你了，小狗，还展开了翅膀。我对你一清二楚。我说的就是我的信誉。
She looked at the bird then, a certified goner. The wren whispered softly, as if to confirm, and then she lunged forward, beheading the worm.
它随后看向那只鸟，一个注定要完蛋的家伙。鹪鹩轻声低语，仿佛在确认，然后它猛扑过去，砍下了蠕虫的头。
Objection.
反对。
The cat yelled.
猫大喊。
She's eating my witness.
它在吃我的证人。
The bird, in a grand show of physical fitness, finished the worm and returned to her perch, the lowest-hung branch of a young silver birch.
那只鸟在一场伟大的体能表演中，吃完了蠕虫，回到了它的栖木上，那是一棵年轻银桦树最低的树枝。
The cat called a witness, a chubby black cricket I'd seen once or twice in my room eat a ticket to movies or plays. This thing, it ate paper. It's body was small, just the size of a caper.
猫传唤了一名证人，一只胖乎乎的黑色蟋蟀，我曾在我的房间里一两次看到它吃掉电影或戏剧票。这东西，它吃纸。它的身体很小，只有刺山柑那么大。
I'm a cricket, I am, and to hell with your court,
我是只蟋蟀，没错，去你的法庭，
Said the cricket, her vocal cords fierce in retort.
蟋蟀说道，它的声带愤怒地反驳道。
I have no use for your system. It's false and oppressive. The lawyer's behavior is passive-aggressive. You're saying you want me to be more specific? I'll tell you I find your whole species horrific. We live day to day, us and grasshoppers too. You bark and you chirp, you low or you mew, then head to your nest for a night's hibernation, while we're out there fighting for true liberation. You rise from your beds and meet in this clearing to practice your justice. It's all profiteering. Your system's disgusting. It's rotten and stinky, and if you think I'll raise my right hand or my pinkie in honor to you, then you are quite mistaken.
我不需要你们的制度。它是虚伪且压迫的。律师的行为是被动攻击型的。你是说你想让我更具体一点吗？我告诉你，我觉得你们整个物种都很可怕。我们日复一日地活着，我们还有蚱蜢也是。你们吠叫，你们鸣叫，你们哞哞叫或喵喵叫，然后回到巢里冬眠一晚，而我们却在外面为真正的解放而战。你们从床上爬起来，在这个空地上开会，练习你们的公正。这纯粹是牟利。你们的制度恶心、腐烂且发臭，如果你认为我会为了向你们致敬而举起我的右手或小指，那你就大错特错了。
I saw something, true, but no statement I'm making. I won't say a word till you promise protection.
我的确看到了什么，但我不会做任何陈述。在你们承诺保护我之前，我一个字也不会说。
Contempt,
藐视法庭，
Cried the bird. The cat yelled,
鸟喊道。猫大喊，
Objection.
反对。
This justice you claim, it's all based on species. I'd rather kneel down on the ground and eat feces than kowtow to you and your justice-achieving. I'm no friend of yours. Do you hear me? I'm leaving.
你们声称的这种公正，完全是基于物种歧视。我宁愿跪在地上吃粪便，也不愿向你们和你们的所谓公正屈服。我不是你们的朋友。听到了吗？我要走了。
The court was in chaos. The cricket hopped off. She flew through the air just like Baryshnikov. The bird then, she followed it into the thicket and returned having eaten that hot-tempered cricket. There was no objection, no cry of foul play. The judge and the lawyers gave a silent OK.
法庭陷入了混乱。蟋蟀跳开了。它像巴雷什尼科夫（Baryshnikov）一样飞向空中。那只鸟随后追进灌木丛，回来时已经吃掉了那只脾气暴躁的蟋蟀。没有人反对，没有人抗议犯规。法官和律师们给了一个沉默的许可。
Next witness,
下一位证人，
The judge barked.
法官吠叫道。
Allow me to mention we're holding this court with the sole good intention of seeking the truth, of meriting justice. It helps when you call up a witness who will trust us.
请允许我提一下，我们召开这次庭审的唯一良好初衷是寻求真相，实现公正。传唤一个信任我们的证人是有帮助的。
Your honor,
法官大人，
The bird said.
鸟说。
I now call a squirrel, a trustworthy witness, a very nice girl. Hard-working and thrifty, she lives in that elm. I'm hoping my colleague will not overwhelm or badger my witness. She's timid and shy.
我现在传唤一只松鼠，一个值得信赖的证人，一个非常好的女孩。她勤劳且节俭，住在榆树里。我希望我的同事不会压迫或骚扰我的证人。她很胆小害羞。
The judge took an aspirin and shouted out,
法官吃了一片阿司匹林，大喊道，
Why don't you bring on this witness. Enough of your chatter. Let's hope that this squirrel can finish the matter. I'm tired and hungry, so please let's proceed.
你为什么不把证人带上来。你的废话够多了。让我们希望这只松鼠能结束这件事吧。我累了也饿了，所以请继续吧。
The cat took a watch from his pocket.
猫从口袋里掏出一块怀表。
Indeed, you're stalling this court with your warbling and rambling. I'm thinking, Your Honor, defense is just gambling. She's playing for time. It's a transparent tactic. Some call it clever. I call it didactic.
确实，你用你的喋喋不休和东拉西扯拖延了法庭的时间。法官大人，我觉得辩方只是在赌博。她在拖延时间。这是一种透明的策略。有人称它为聪明。我称它为说教。
Your Honor, forgive me. I call your attention to my leading witness, that squirrel I mentioned.
法官大人，请原谅。我提请您注意我的主要证人，就是我提到的那只松鼠。
There was no need to prompt her, no need to coerce. The squirrel entered talking. She set down her purse. And, crossing her legs, lady-like, at the shin, the squirrel eyewitness began to weigh in.
不需要提示她，也不需要强迫。松鼠边走边说。她放下钱包。然后，像淑女一样交叉双腿坐在小腿上，这只松鼠证人开始发表看法。
I saw it. I did, the whole thing, and it reeks. I was sitting there calmly, with nuts in my cheeks. I gather them daily. These nuts are my diet. An acorn, a pecan-- you name it, I'll try it. Sometimes I'll hide them. I'll dig them a grave for some later time when we have a cold wave. It ain't easy digging through thick ice and snow.
我看到了。我确实看到了，整件事，太臭了。我当时正安静地坐在那里，腮帮子里塞满了坚果。我每天收集它们。这些坚果是我的饮食。橡子、山核桃——你随便说，我都会尝试。有时我会藏起来。我会把它们埋进坟墓，留到以后寒潮的时候吃。在厚厚的冰雪中挖掘可不容易。
Objection,
反对，
The cat cried.
猫大喊。
I think we all know that winter is frosty. It's chilly and tough. In terms of her hardship, we've all heard enough.
我想我们都知道冬天很冷。它寒冷而艰难。至于她的苦难，我们已经听得够多了。
Get on with your story. Enough of your woes.
继续讲你的故事。你的哀叹够多了。
Yes, sir,
是的，长官。
Said the squirrel.
松鼠说道。
Well, the rest of it goes, I was searching for food then was out on my rounds. My sister remarked that I'd gained a few pounds in my hips and my shoulders. She thought it looked smashing. I respect her opinion, and so I was dashing to something I saw. It resembled a kernel of corn, so I thought, but it seems the infernal nugget in question turned out to be gum. It was chewed in a wad just the size of crumb. I was out of my mind, man, I wanted a snack.
嗯，剩下的是这样的，当时我正在觅食，顺便巡视一下。我妹妹评论说我的臀部和肩膀长了点肉。她觉得这样看起来很棒。我尊重她的意见，所以我正冲向我看到的东西。我以为那是一粒玉米，但那个该死的金块似乎是一块口香糖。它被嚼成了一团，只有面包屑那么大。我当时快疯了，伙计，我想吃点零食。
Objection, Your Honor, she's getting off-track,
法官大人，反对，她跑题了。
The cat lawyer cried.
猫律师大喊道。
Let's get on with the crime.
让我们继续审理这个案子吧。
Your Honor,
法官大人，
The bird said.
那只鸟说道。
My witness needs time to set up her scene of emotional stress. She's said to have suffered from mental duress.
我的证人需要时间来陈述她当时的情绪压力。据说她遭受了精神折磨。
So, anyway, right, if my memory serves, I was searching the ground for some type of hors d'oeuvres when I heard in the distance the sound of a voice. It sounded quite angry, so I made the choice. I peeked through the window and sat on my haunches, and then I became, for a brief while, unconscious. It happens sometimes. I have these brief spells. I can't say for certain, but something compels my brain to relax, causing me to black out. You know, I was hit in the head with a large brussel sprout last summer. I think it was early July. I think that's the reason. I'm not certain why.
所以，总之，没错，如果我的记忆没出错的话，我当时正在地上找些开胃小菜，这时我听到了远处传来一个声音。听起来很愤怒，所以我做出了选择。我透过窗户偷看，蹲坐在后腿上，然后有那么一会儿，我失去了知觉。这种情况偶尔会发生。我有这种短暂的晕厥。我说不准，但有什么东西迫使我的大脑放松，导致我昏迷过去。你知道，去年夏天我的头被一个大抱子甘蓝砸到了。我想是在七月初。我想原因就在这儿。我不确定具体原因。
I'm sorry,
我很抱歉，
The cat said.
那只猫说。
Your mind is so frail. I'm wondering, though, if your story entails the facts of this case. Is there any connection between the accused and your brain imperfection?
你的心智太脆弱了。不过我在想，你的故事是否包含本案的事实。被告和你的大脑缺陷之间有什么联系吗？
Technically, yes,
从技术上讲，是的。
The squirrel said, beaming.
松鼠喜气洋洋地说道。
My body was there, but my mind was dreaming. I was there at the scene. That I know for a fact. I was hoping by speaking I might extract some detail, something I maybe could mention to justify all of this lavish attention. I find it exciting, dramatic, suspense. It all suits me perfect, because in a sense, I enjoy public speaking. I love center stage.
我的身体在那儿，但我的思想在做梦。我在现场。这点我敢肯定。我希望通过发言能提取一些细节，也许我可以提到一些东西来证明所有这些过度关注的合理性。我觉得这很刺激、很戏剧化、很有悬念。这一切都很适合我，因为在某种意义上，我喜欢公开演讲。我热爱舞台中心。
The bird then approached, feathers standing in rage.
那只鸟随后走了过来，羽毛因愤怒而竖起。
You said you had seen things, that you were compliant and had information concerning my client.
你说过你看到了东西，你很配合，并且掌握了关于我委托人的信息。
I might have, you know, but I can't say for certain. I know what I told you, but now I'm reverting. Is this microphone on? Hello? Do you mind if I sing? [SINGS]
我可能是这么说过，你知道，但我不能确定。我知道我告诉过你什么，但现在我要收回了。这个麦克风开着吗？喂？你不介意我唱首歌吧？[唱歌]
The bird slapped the stand with the tip of her wing and spat in discuss.
那只鸟用翅膀尖拍打着支架，厌恶地吐了口唾沫。
Your witness,
证人交给你了，
She said. The cat flexed his paws, and then used them to shred that squirrel to ribbons. He tore her to bits. And ate everything but her eyes and armpits. And then he pounced forward and firmly procured between his firm jaws that lawyering bird.
她说。猫绷紧了爪子，然后用它们把那只松鼠撕成了碎片。他把她撕得粉碎。吃掉了除眼睛和腋窝以外的所有东西。然后他扑向前，用坚硬的下颚牢牢地抓住了那只当律师的鸟。
Objection, Your Honor. I feel I'm being eaten. I don't like the way my colleague is treatin' the legal profession, especially me. I'm soon to become a full-fledged amputee.
反对，法官大人。我觉得我正在被吃掉。我不喜欢我的同事对待法律职业的方式，尤其是对我。我很快就要变成一个彻头彻尾的截肢者了。
That was all that I heard. The rest was too muffled. I watched for a while as the two of them scuffled. The cat took the bird right down to the beak. The judge rose, then asking if now he might speak.
这就是我所听到的一切。其余的太模糊了。我看着他们两个扭打了一会儿。那只猫把那只鸟一直咬到了喙部。法官站了起来，问他现在是否可以发言。
To the cat in my chambers, a brief legal chat.
叫那只猫到我的办公室来，我们要进行简短的法律谈话。
The judge then walked off, and I watched as the cat foolishly followed that judge past a stump to a field of tires once used as a dump. I heard the cat hiss then, and then [INAUDIBLE]. I can't say for certain who struck the first blow, but I can say who won. I know that the judge stepped out of his chambers unable to budge. He belched and he sagged, both lips heavy with fur, and looked out at the courtroom where others once were.
法官随后走开了，我看着那只猫愚蠢地跟着法官经过一个树桩，来到一个曾经当作垃圾场的轮胎场。我听到猫发出嘶嘶声，然后[听不清]。我不能肯定是谁先动的手，但我可以说出谁赢了。我知道法官走出办公室时无法挪动。他打着嗝，身体下垂，嘴唇上粘满了毛，望着曾经有其他人在的法庭。
I find you not guilty,
我判你无罪，
He said to my spaniel.
他对我的猎犬说。
But if I every hear so much as a granule of trouble from you, then I'll put you away.
但如果我再听到你惹出一丁点麻烦，我就把你关起来。
Thank you, Your Honor.
谢谢，法官大人。
I heard Kathleen say.
我听到凯瑟琳说。
Go on, now. Get out of here. Hurry along. Get back to your home, back to where you belong.
走吧，离开这儿。快走。回你的家去，回到你该去的地方。
I waited for Kathleen beside a small creek. She passed me, despondent, refusing to speak. And me, I returned to my comfortable bed, thinking of how, by some fluke, I'd been led to animal court, that harsh hostile scene, that by chance thought to spare my companion, Kathleen.
我在一条小溪边等凯瑟琳。她从我身边走过，垂头丧气，拒绝说话。而我，回到了我舒适的床上，想着我是如何因为某种侥幸被带到动物法庭，那个残酷而敌对的地方，那个偶然想宽恕我的同伴凯瑟琳的地方。
The Pinetree Gang. Amy Sedaris, David Rakoff, Toby Warey, Stacy Goldstein, Jackie Hoffman, Nora Ladonny, Sarah Tire, and Richard Zaragoza. Story by David Sedaris.
松树帮。艾米·塞德丽丝，大卫·拉科夫，托比·瓦里，斯泰西·戈尔茨坦，杰基·霍夫曼，诺拉·拉多尼，莎拉·泰尔和理查德·萨拉戈萨。故事作者大卫·塞达里斯。
[MUSIC -- "ROCKY RACCOON" BY LENA HORNE]
[音乐 -- 莉娜·霍恩演唱的《摇滚浣熊》]
Act Three, The Moment When Humans Stopped Being Animals. If you ask anthropologists the moment that humans divide off from the animal kingdom, it's the moment that our ape-like ancestors started walking upright on two legs. For people who don't believe that God created the earth in six days, that moment is our origin. That's our Book of Genesis. That is the mythic point where we began. But nobody knows why these pre-humans started walking around on two legs instead of loping around on all fours the way that most animals do. There are different theories but no consensus among scientists.
第三幕，人类不再是动物的那一刻。如果你问人类学家人类从动物界分离出来的时刻，那就是我们类人猿祖先开始直立行走在两条腿上的那一刻。对于那些不相信上帝在六天内创造地球的人来说，那一刻就是我们的起源。那是我们的《创世记》。那是我们开始的神话起点。但没有人知道为什么这些前人类开始用两条腿走路，而不是像大多数动物那样四肢着地奔跑。有不同的理论，但科学家之间没有共识。
Well, 10 years ago, Scott Carrier decided to do some research on his own, and he made this radio report.
嗯，10年前，斯科特·卡里尔决定自己做一些研究，他制作了这个广播报道。
Oh, there they go.
噢，它们在那儿。
What?
什么？
There they go. Do you see them crossing over there?
它们在那儿。你看到它们在那儿穿过去了吗？
No.
没有。
Over to the right, quite a ways away in fact. Way out there.
在右边，事实上相当远。在那儿很远的地方。
A couple of years ago, my brother and I went to Wyoming to run down an antelope.
几年前，我和我哥哥去了怀俄明州追赶一只羚羊。
I only see three over there.
我只看到那边有三只。
Well, there were about eight down there.
嗯，刚才下面大约有八只。
Yeah.
是的。
It was August and our plan was to chase one animal until it overheated and collapsed.
那是八月，我们的计划是追赶一只动物，直到它过热并倒下。
It just took off on running.
它只是开始跑了起来。
OK.
好的。
Do you want to follow it?
你想跟着它吗？
Yeah.
是的。
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
We had good reasons for what we were doing. One was that it seemed entirely possible. Another had to do with an argument concerning human evolution. It's a scientific argument, so it takes a few minutes to explain.
我们做这件事有充分的理由。其一，它看起来完全可行。另一个与关于人类进化的论点有关。这是一个科学论点，所以需要几分钟来解释。
Remember the scene in 2001, where an ape-man realizes he can use a bone as a weapon and murders another ape-man? Then he throws the bone in the air and it becomes a space station orbiting the earth. The theory behind this scene is that we separated from the apes when we stood upright and freed our hands to make and use tools, especially weapon-type tools for hunting and killing other animals. It's called the hunting hypothesis, and there's nothing wrong with it except that we don't have any physical evidence to support it. We just haven't found any tools or weapons that are that old.
记得《2001太空漫游》里的那一幕吗，猿人意识到他可以使用骨头作为武器并杀死了另一个猿人？然后他把骨头扔向空中，它变成了一个绕地球运行的空间站。这个场景背后的理论是，当我们直立行走并解放双手去制造和使用工具，特别是用于狩猎和杀害其他动物的武器类工具时，我们就从猿类中分化出来了。这被称为狩猎假说，它没有任何问题，除了我们没有任何物理证据来支持它。我们只是还没有发现那么古老的工具或武器。
Well, some of the work that my brother does as a biologist made him interested in another theory of human evolution. You might call it the running hypothesis. He believed that he and I were probably good enough runners to be able to run down big game without using any weapons at all. And he thought that if we could do it, then maybe our early ancestors could have done it too.
嗯，我哥哥作为一名生物学家所做的一些工作让他对人类进化的另一个理论产生了兴趣。你可以称之为奔跑假说。他相信他和我也许是足够优秀的跑步者，能够不使用任何武器就追上大型猎物。他认为如果我们能做到，那么我们早期的祖先也许也能做到。
Shortly before we went to Wyoming, I went to see Owen Lovejoy. He teaches anthropology at Kent State University. We talked about the running hypothesis, and he thought it was pretty funny.
在我们去怀俄明州之前不久，我去看望了欧文·洛夫乔伊。他在肯特州立大学教授人类学。我们谈到了奔跑假说，他觉得这很有趣。
I mean, think about it for a minute. I mean, what game are they going to run down? Things like wildebeest or something?
我的意思是，想一想。我的意思是，他们要追赶什么猎物？像角马之类的东西？
Uh-huh. Zebra.
嗯哼。斑马。
And they're just going to start off running after this thing without any advanced weaponry of any kind. They've got no spears, no bow and arrow, and they just start running after a wildebeest.
他们只是要开始跑着追这种东西，没有任何先进的武器。他们没有矛，没有弓箭，他们只是开始跑着追一只角马。
Yeah. Well, I think that's the idea, that they--
是的。嗯，我想这就是那个想法，他们——
Uh-huh. The weak link in that whole behavior that you're describing is the inability of the animal to run any faster because it's so damn slow. And it's so damn slow because it's a clumsy biped. Is that an animal adapted to hunting? Slow, awkward, little, no olfaction, no protective vision. If it were an effective quadruped, it could do everything that you're describing in half the time. I mean, imagine a bunch of Paiute Indians that could run as rapidly and as successful as a German Shepherd dog. They'd catch the thing in three minutes and devour it.
嗯哼。你描述的整个行为中薄弱的一环是动物无法跑得更快，因为它太慢了。它之所以那么慢，是因为它是一个笨拙的双足动物。那是适应狩猎的动物吗？缓慢、笨拙、弱小，没有嗅觉，没有保护性视力。如果它是一个有效的四足动物，它能在一半的时间内完成你描述的一切。我的意思是，想象一群能像德国牧羊犬一样快速且成功奔跑的派尤特印第安人。他们会在三分钟内抓住它并吞食它。
Well, I just happen to have a German Shepherd, and I take him with me when I go running.
嗯，我正好有一只德国牧羊犬，我跑步的时候带着它。
Let's go.
走吧。
And Lovejoy's right. He's a better runner than I am. In fact, most of the time, he'd rather have me take my bicycle. So there's no question about me being slower. But as far as being clumsy, Lovejoy calls bipedalism clumsy because of reasons that have to do with biomechanics. Running bipedally takes twice as much energy as running quadrupedally That is, when my dog and I run, he uses half the energy that I do. So Lovejoy and many other anthropologists think it's crazy to assume that the survival strategy of the early hominids involved running after quadrupeds. They've just got us beat, both in terms of speed and efficiency.
洛夫乔伊是对的。他比我跑得快。事实上，大多数时候，他宁愿我骑自行车。所以关于我跑得慢这一点毫无疑问。但至于笨拙，洛夫乔伊称双足行走为笨拙，是因为生物力学的原因。双足奔跑比四足奔跑消耗两倍的能量。也就是说，当我和我的狗跑步时，他消耗的能量是我的一半。所以洛夫乔伊和其他许多人类学家认为，假设早期人类的生存策略包括追逐四足动物是很疯狂的。他们在速度和效率上都胜过我们。
But the thing is, if my dog and I go running in the summer in the middle of the day, when temperatures hit 85 to 100 or more degrees, it's a whole different ballgame. He'll come with me and run for a while, but then he walks and lags behind. And sometimes he just goes home. So if I'm an awkward and clumsy biped, why can I outrun my dog?
但问题是，如果我和我的狗在夏天中午气温达到85到100华氏度或更高时跑步，那完全是另一回事。他会跟我一起跑一会儿，但随后他会走路并落在后面。有时他干脆回家了。那么如果我是一个笨拙的双足动物，为什么我能跑赢我的狗？
Well, it's because he overheats. The main way that he and most other quadrupeds cool themselves when they run is by breathing. The air coming in and going out of their mouth evaporates water off their tongues. We do this too, but we do it all over our body by sweating, and then we get a nice flow of air directly over our skin, because we don't have a fur coat. So we can't run as fast as a quadruped, but we can run farther, especially in high heat. And when you remember that we're using twice the energy, this seems like a very strange biological paradox. And it was this paradox, combined with the argument about not being able to hunt without tools, that made my brother and I decide that it was time to try to run down an antelope.
嗯，那是因为他过热了。他和其他大多数四足动物在奔跑时降温的主要方式是通过呼吸。空气从嘴里进出，蒸发掉舌头上的水分。我们也这样做，但我们通过出汗在全身进行，而且我们有一股气流直接掠过皮肤，因为我们没有皮毛。所以我们跑得不如四足动物快，但我们能跑得更远，特别是在高温下。当你记住我们使用了两倍的能量时，这看起来像是一个非常奇怪的生物学悖论。正是这个悖论，加上关于没有工具就无法狩猎的论点，让我和哥哥决定尝试追赶一只羚羊。
Antilocapra americana, the pronghorn, the second-fastest land mammal on the planet. We thought that if we could keep one running for two hours on a hot day, we'd have it beat.
叉角羚，地球上第二快的陆地哺乳动物。我们认为如果我们能让它在炎热的一天跑上两个小时，我们就能赢过它。
What happened?
发生了什么？
They didn't give me a chance. I was able to follow them for about 30 minutes, but the problem was I wasn't sure if I was following the same ones I started following. Because I started out following four-- a buck, two does, and a younger one. And after about 10 minutes, they ran into a group of about five more antelope, went over a hill. And then on the other side of the hill, they broke into two groups again. And so I think I ended up following the same four, but I couldn't be sure. And I followed them for another 15 minutes, and then they ran into a much larger group, ran for a ways. And I followed that larger group for a while, and then that group broke into at least two more groups.
它们没给我机会。我能跟着它们大约30分钟，但问题是我不确定我跟着的是不是我开始跟的那几只。因为我开始跟着四只——一头雄性，两头雌性，还有一只年轻的。大约10分钟后，它们跑进了一群大约五只以上的羚羊里，翻过了一座山。然后在那座山的另一边，它们又分成了两组。所以我认为我最终跟着的还是那四只，但我无法确定。我又跟着它们跑了15分钟，然后它们跑进了一大群羚羊里，跑了一段路。我跟着那一大群羚羊跑了一会儿，然后那群羚羊又分成了至少两组。
And at that point I just sort of gave up and quit following them, because I didn't know which individuals I was chasing. And then I got confused on the roads. Where's the road we were on? Down here? OK, what happened was I came out on this road, way over there somewhere. And I got lost. I didn't know, really, where I was. I was walking along that road for about 15 minutes. I felt like that was the wrong direction. So we started over there. They ran a circle there. I don't remember crossing this road, but I must have, originally, early on.
在那一刻，我就放弃了，停止了追踪，因为我不知道我在追哪几只。然后我在路上迷路了。我们走的那条路在哪儿？在这儿下面吗？好的，发生的情况是我走到了这条路上，在那儿某处。我迷路了。我真的不知道我在哪儿。我沿着那条路走了大约15分钟。我觉得那是错误的方向。所以我们在那儿重新开始。它们在那儿绕了一个圈。我不记得穿过这条路了，但我一定是穿过，起初。
This one?
这一条？
They ran in a circle. They came back.
它们绕了一个圈。它们又回来了。
Hey there listeners, I'm just going to interrupt right here. This is an old episode from 1996, and we have a music rights issue. So we can't play you this next little patch of the story. But I'm just going to summarize it for you, very briefly. It's not that long of a section.
嘿，听众朋友们，我在这里插播一下。这是一集1996年的旧节目，我们有音乐版权问题。所以我们不能为您播放下一小段故事。但我会为您做一个非常简短的总结。这一部分并不长。
Basically, what happens is, Scott and his brother talk about what to do next. And his brother says they should go out and look for more. Scott asks, you mean forget about these? And his brother says he doesn't know where these ones went.
基本上发生的事情是，斯科特和他的兄弟讨论下一步该做什么。他的兄弟说他们应该出去找更多的猎物。斯科特问，你的意思是忘了这些吗？他兄弟说他不知道这些跑哪儿去了。
Scott writes, It could have been the Serengeti-- orange and green and purple plains, a hot sun, thin high clouds, blue mountains on the horizon. It could have been the Serengeti, but we were no primitive hunters. We quickly realized we knew nothing about the animal we were chasing or the land we were running on. We ran after several herds that first day without much success.
斯科特写道，这可能是塞伦盖蒂——橙色、绿色和紫色的平原，炽热的太阳，稀薄的高云，地平线上蓝色的山脉。这可能是塞伦盖蒂，但我们不是原始猎人。我们很快意识到我们对正在追赶的动物和我们奔跑的土地一无所知。那天我们追赶了好几群羚羊，但没有取得什么成功。
Alright, we'll pick up the story from there.
好了，我们从那儿继续讲故事。
That night, sleeping out, I remember feeling very high in terms of elevation, like being dizzy. There weren't any clouds in the sky, and it just seemed like too much open space. Satellites in orbit, the moon in orbit, and antelope in the bushes, chewing their cuds and laughing amongst themselves.
那天晚上，露宿在外，我记得海拔很高，有一种眩晕的感觉。天空中没有云，空间看起来太开阔了。轨道上的卫星，轨道上的月亮，灌木丛中的羚羊，反刍着，互相嬉笑。
The next morning, we ate a breakfast of chocolate chip cookies and orange juice, and walked around waiting for the air to heat up.
第二天早上，我们吃了巧克力曲奇和橙汁当早餐，到处走动，等待空气变热。
What is it?
那是什么？
It's a white-tailed jackrabbit.
那是白尾杰克兔。
We found dead animals, bare bones, an abandoned house.
我们发现了死去的动物、裸露的骨头和一间废弃的房子。
You think someone used to live here?
你认为曾经有人住在这里吗？
We saw dust devils, horned toads, an eagle. We found a small lake, some badlands, and a rattlesnake.
我们看到了尘卷风、角蜥和一只老鹰。我们发现了一个小湖、一些荒地和一条响尾蛇。
Wow.
哇。
It never did get very hot that day, but in the afternoon, we had a good long chase after a female and two males. They ran in circles around an area of about 10 square miles. There were two hills and a long smooth valley in between, and the chase went up and around and back and forth between these hills, the antelope running short periods of time but covering long distances and then stopping and waiting for us to catch up. The two males ran behind the female, as if they were trying to protect her, and sometimes they'd all go in different directions, but we stayed behind the female and the males would eventually rejoin her.
那天天气一直没变得太热，但在下午，我们对一只雌羚羊和两只雄羚羊进行了长时间的追逐。它们在一个大约10平方英里的区域内绕圈奔跑。那里有两座小山，中间是一条平坦狭长的山谷。追逐的过程就是在这些山丘之间上下穿梭、来回往复。羚羊短时间奔跑，覆盖很长距离，然后停下来等我们赶上。两只雄羚羊跑在雌羚羊身后，好像在保护她，有时它们会向不同方向奔跑，但我们始终跟在雌羚羊后面，雄羚羊最终会重新聚拢到她身边。
One thing we'd learned the day before was that we could run much less distance than the antelopes by staying well inside their circle, and we were also starting to communicate with each other over long distances. For instance, if my brother was on top of one of the hills, and he could see where the antelope were going, he'd point, and I wouldn't have to run to the top of the hill. So we were running after these three and feeling pretty good about not letting them ditch us, and a couple times, we even got within 50 yards of them. And I'd look into their eyes, trying to see some sign of fear or fatigue, but all I kept seeing were very quiet animals that seemed to know exactly who we were, what we were proposing, and didn't seem to be in the least bit worried.
我们前一天学到的一件事是，如果我们待在它们奔跑圈子的内侧，我们跑的距离会比羚羊少得多。我们也开始尝试在远距离之间进行沟通。例如，如果我哥哥在其中一座山顶上，他能看到羚羊的去向，他就会指向那个方向，这样我就不必非要跑到山顶上。所以我们追着这三只羚羊，感觉很棒，没有让它们甩掉我们，有好几次，我们甚至靠近到了距离它们50码以内的地方。我盯着它们的眼睛看，试图从中寻找恐惧或疲惫的迹象，但我看到的始终是十分平静的动物，它们似乎非常清楚我们是谁，我们在做什么，而且看起来一点儿也不担心。
Anyway, we ran after these three for about an hour, and then they found a large herd, or the herd found them. And they ran up and over a hill, and by the time we got to the top of the hill, the herd had split into three groups of about three or four antelopes each. And each of the groups seemed to have at least one female that looked exactly like the one we'd started chasing-- the magic shell game trick again. We weren't really all that physically tired, mainly mentally beaten, and we went home.
总之，我们追了这三只羚羊大约一个小时，然后它们发现了一个大羚羊群，或者是大羚羊群发现了它们。它们翻过一座山丘，当我们到达山顶时，羚羊群已经分成了三组，每组大约三到四只。每一组似乎都至少有一只看起来和我们开始追逐的那只一模一样的雌羚羊——又是“魔术壳游戏”的诡计。我们身体上其实并不怎么累，主要是精神上被打败了，于是我们回了家。
I haven't gone back to Wyoming for the purpose of chasing antelope, but I drive through there sometimes on my way somewhere else. And one time last spring I was going east, and there was a train along the highway also going east at about the same speed. And suddenly there were three antelope running alongside the engine, chasing it. It was incredible. It was even more incredible to see the three of them simultaneously speed up, pull out in front of the engine, and fly across the tracks.
我后来没再为了追羚羊而回过怀俄明州，但我有时在去别处时会开车经过那里。去年春天有一次我向东行驶，公路旁有一列火车也在向东行驶，速度差不多。突然，有三只羚羊在火车头旁边奔跑，追着它跑。那真是太不可思议了。更不可思议的是，它们三只同时加速，跑到火车头前面，飞快地横穿了轨道。
I pulled over and waited for the train to go by, and there they were. Three young males, looking back at me with those same black eyes and hardly breathing at all.
我把车停在路边，等火车经过，它们就在那里。三只年轻的雄羚羊，用那双同样的黑眼睛看着我，几乎连气都不喘。
In the years since he first recorded that story, Scott has put it into a collection of his stories, a book called, simply, Running After Antelope.
自从斯科特第一次记录下这个故事后的几年里，他将这个故事收录进了他的故事集中，书名很简单，就叫《追逐羚羊》。
[MUSIC -- "I WAN'NA BE LIKE YOU" BY LOUIS PRIMA]
[音乐——路易·普里玛演唱的《我想成为你》]
Well, the great Louis Prima, from The Jungle Book soundtrack. Our program was produced today by Peter Clowney and me, with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors for this show, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rockland. Original music for the opening story in today's program by Jeff Muller and Jason Noble. Other musical help from Mr. John Connors and the Mysterious Rumpety Rattles. And you know, you can download today's program and our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
好的，这是来自《森林王子》原声带中伟大的路易·普里玛。我们今天的节目由彼得·克劳尼和我制作，艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与制作。本节目的特约编辑有保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·洛克兰。今天节目开场故事的原创音乐由杰夫·穆勒和杰森·诺布尔创作。其他音乐帮助来自约翰·康纳斯先生和神秘的Rumpety Rattles。你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载今天的节目和我们的档案。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. [FUNDING CREDITS] WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who treats his employees this way.
《美国生活》节目由国际公共广播电台发行。[资助鸣谢] WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他就是这样对待员工的。
Must bite, must bite, must-- no, no, nice, nice-- bite, must bite, must bite.
必须咬，必须咬，必须——不，不，乖，乖——咬，必须咬，必须咬。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带给大家更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。